[Music]
the future is a grassroots movement
organization that I that I found it but
it's a whole tribe of women and men who
want to empower other women and we want
to give opportunities to women in the
arts because that's where I have my
footing in music and in film we want to
give more wings to to women's ideas all
of us feel like it's really sad when we
look at the opportunities that don't go
to women this is a male-dominated
industry and we have to do something
about that
you know so I'm really excited to
partner with a brand like Belvedere who
said what can we do because two years
ago I'm not gonna lie three years ago I
was very frustrated I didn't have any
money I didn't have I didn't have anyone
to help you know help with this project
I just knew I have big ideas and I knew
that my heart was in the right place you
have so many incredible women here
supporting you Lupita Zoi so many more
talk to me about what those women mean
to you and having that community Wow
well the women you name are my friends
but I'm so inspired by them everyone was
handpicked to be here these these are
the women that keep me grounded that
keep me motivated that encouraged me
that empowered me when I look at them I
always feel like I need to be doing more
and so I'm just so thankful to have
their support and and everyone in this
room support it's not just about me it's
about us what can we do together what
can I do for you and and they've come
today and they're showing up because
we're gonna do it together
[Music]